good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy hump day oh my
god i didn't even realize i feel like a
reinvigorated spirit happy hump day i'm
someone you love i'm doing that today
theo's here finally on a hump day it's
been a while and we're just ready to get
down to
let's get down to business i'm gonna
talk as long as i can until jackie's
this might be a record for the longest
intro before i get to speak theo is here
but he's on the floor like on my blanket
just having a bone of a time so we're
not gonna disturb him but that's why
this blanket is like messily next to me
just because like theo is living his
best life and who am i to disturb i
think that maybe today i set the record
for talking so long because like you
finally mentioned it all yesterday you
mentioned i thought me mentioning it all
would have the aversive effect where
you're like super aware of it it's like
good morning millennials it's wednesday
how are you no i'm just like now it's
kind of like self-conscious and like i
find myself babbling on i'm like is it
too long is it too short should i say
should i go like you kind of made me i
don't know like hate myself
oh i'm sorry that wasn't
that wasn't the intended effect it was
just for you to be more mindful of it
you know
we all want to say hello to the audience
no that's good i i needed more things to
be mindful of as it comes as it refers
like myself so i'm really grateful to
have another thing that i should be
insecure about i cannot thank you enough
you are the most dramatic person
alive that is true that is true we have
an amazing show you guys because
actually not that much happened in the
world yesterday but you know we could
talk about
wait what's going down
theo's wait theo do daddoo wait jackie
can you grab the bone
it's red it looks like he's maybe like
bleeding you see
no i think it's like bone stuff you sure
i don't know get it away from me okay
let me see no it's not bone stuff i feel
like his gums are bleeding oh my god do
you have gingivitis my boy i'm sorry i
have to take this away from you oh my
god and he's not gonna be happy right
it's blood yeah and he has like red tint
on his
mouth
okay can you keep talking i'm just gonna
toss this sure i mean i don't know how
you segway from that theo's bleeding
from his mouth but we do have a great
show for you today i think claudia was
about to say that even though not much
happened in the world yesterday we can
really talk about anything and most
importantly i feel as though we need to
talk about roni and love island yeah
actually i was gonna say um we have a
really good tv recap because even though
i would say both of the shows we're
watching are definitely at some sort of
crossroads in their entertainment value
i thought both of last night's episodes
um of respective shows were very
thought-provoking and i do have some
thoughts finally i'm looking forward to
hearing your thoughts and with love
island there's been a lot of off-island
drama because a lot of like the really
hot contestants aren't even on the show
right so they're doing all these
instagram lives dropping tea speaking on
conspiracy theories and i can't wait to
get into it honestly no me too and so
before we get into everything so that we
can get into all of that i just want to
let everyone know that we are recording
the redheads tonight clara and the sun
book review so if you have questions
about the book please email us at the
redheadsbookclub gmail.com and i don't
know if you know this but you can ask us
anything about any book at the redheads
bookclub gmail.com i didn't know that it
doesn't have to be book of the month
specific it could be about like other
books you saw us reading this month so
i'm really excited to get back together
with the girls because this
episode was one week delayed and so it
just feels like a super long time since
i've seen all the gals
the jazzy gals are getting back together
and i finished the book last night and
it was it was a journey it really was
and i think we're gonna have some
heated conversations because the
snatcher made it known this morning she
woke up and said and wrote in the chat
this book is terrible she woke up and
chose violence she woke up and shows
violence i disagree with her personally
i know dana does too um rebecca said i'm
saving my thoughts for the episode so we
don't even know what rebecca thinks you
don't have a question because like when
you're normally reading a book and you
don't like it you don't finish it as a
redhead can you not finish a book like
it's part of your job it's never been
right okay it's never been done the job
is to finish the book you know and the
the thinking is that we're choosing
books that are
either have a good goodreads rating or
new york times bestsellers were highly
recommended so it's like someone
somewhere said this book was good just
[ __ ] finish it yeah yeah i know i
feel that i was just wondering about the
logistics of what it entails to be a
redhead and clara and the sun was a new
york times bestseller and the author
kazuo ishiguro is like has nobel prize
laureate all of the prizes so like
finishes both you know and i feel like
it's just really important that we
respect new york times best-selling
authors around here i couldn't agree
more and that's what i do every day it's
true you wake up and choose to respect
new york times best-selling authors
every day in every way um i had
something else to say before we dive in
oh yesterday was like the busiest day of
my life we were just like busy busy busy
with work and i spent every ounce of my
free time looking for a new apartment
and i actually spoke to a broker like a
very you know well
knowledged was it ramona singer oh my
god we have to talk about that but
basically i was told like what i want
doesn't exist you know oh really why
which part of it just all of it like
like
type of building in certain location
doesn't really exist
and if it does it's not gonna have like
the space that i want like it's just i
was told very firmly like what you want
doesn't exist especially in your budget
okay so you have to let one part of the
dream go i'm open which part is going
okay so like technically i live in a one
bedroom right now and like it doesn't
make sense to move on to another one
bedroom but like
i don't know i could live without the
second bedroom if i have like a little
like
office like you know what i mean little
alcohol alcove i don't know i'm just i
said i'll look at anything and then
everything i get sent like i just hate
right or can't afford which is like
what's more upsetting than looking at
houses you can't afford like nothing no
nothing it's so sad it's like
work harder do more go on tour okay
you're doing it i know i'm just i'm
feeling like i was so disheartened
actually like after a long day of
looking and searching and speaking
coming up with zero results not that i'm
gonna find an apartment in a day but
just kind of being so disheartened i
felt like really sad
i'm sorry it was emotional for me and
then i was just like looking around my
stupid [ __ ] apartment i'm like you
[ __ ] [ __ ] i still think we should do
apartment swap i think that would be
hysterical obviously we'll patreon it
and maybe we'll each get something out
of it really you want me sleeping in
your bed sure
okay like
sure i don't know i just like have a lot
to do before you come over you know i
mean of course i have to hide everything
yeah like i just have things like i have
to get
i need a safe
totally and there's nothing valuable no
no no just like things
embarrassing personal items totally like
certain pairs of underwear like just no
um
okay i'll think about it yeah i think it
could be fun but speaking of patreon we
did post our first episode of the month
yesterday to get ready with me um i
don't know yesterday i had a
i had a certain joad of eve and i think
i can
kind of trace its origins to the patreon
because i was just feeling myself all
day we took this picture for the toast i
looked so cute and like
everything of the sort and then like
when i got home i just like didn't take
my makeup off i was just like walking
around the house like doing chores
feeling like a goddess and i think i
should patreon every morning because
like i felt so good about myself and
then this morning i woke up with nothing
no patreon i was just like
back to my i felt like i feel pretty
like i had that one day of like ultimate
energy and confidence and then like
today i hit my head on the soulcycle
bike and i'm back to being normal yeah i
feel that i'm sorry but i'm glad you had
that yesterday and i did watch your
patreon video and it was very fun to
watch so if you haven't checked it out
yet head over to patreon.com morning
toast thank you and it's everything to
become a patreon member patreon is our
subscription service for this show is
free always has been always will be
until further notice and we have a
subscription service for 7.99 per month
you get five extra episodes from us
their podcasts their vlogs their
interviews with friends and family it's
super fun and easy and it's always just
like a good time and you get to join the
patreon community access to our facebook
group so check it out great way to get
more content and support your favorite
podcast exactly
okay now i think without further ado
yeah like let's
let's let's do the damn thing let's jump
right in oh just i'm sure it's not a
story but i did see michelle's trailer
for the upcoming season of her
bachelorette journey and i just have to
say like boy did they do
katie dirty like there's just been like
in from what i've seen like very low
budget
very you know
sponsored by cole's energy in all of her
assets that are coming out from her
season the premiere and michelle's was
just like back to that glamorous like i
think one of the best ones was hannah
brown like you know she was cinderella
in a forest you know yeah and michelle
was giving that energy like big ball
down katie we had that skirt yeah we had
the skirt and like the swing she was
like a t-shirt and she's katie yeah and
over a dress and with purple sequins
yeah and she was just in like some
studio with like a white background in
studios
it was sad michelle they brought back
the budget has been brought back it was
really glamorous okay that's really nice
to hear and i really do think that those
photos contributed greatly to us not
watching katie's season like if that's
the looks were being served on day one
katie team katie over a sparkly purple
dress i no but let's dive into the
narrative there
who is she playing like who was she up
against
the world like i don't know team katie
verse team who i think i think it was
like jacenya an homage to like when
katie took on the girls
okay but
the girls were right oh actually no
katie was right katie was right there
for team katie
i can't go back to jay i can't go back
to this dark place
let's move on come on without further
ado
where are you right here being perfect
it is time for the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast and today's episode is brought to
you by public goods the one-stop shop
for sustainable high quality everyday
essentials made from clean ingredients
at an affordable price everything from
coffee to toilet paper shampoo and pet
food they have your new they are your
new everything store thoughtfully
designed for the conscious consumer
rather than buying a bunch of products
from single product brands public goods
you can buy all of your premium
essentials in one place with one
beautiful streamlined aesthetic they
search the globe to find clean healthy
eco-friendly and innovative products
my home is actually full of public goods
products the hand soap is in my guest
room the surface cleaner is in my
kitchen as is olive oil and obviously
all the products are fabulous and
really really good but the best part is
like the packaging they come in it's
very kind of influencer approved it's
like stunning it doesn't really look
like a
surface cleaner it looks like a perfume
honestly right exactly so their whole
brand is like keeping that in mind it's
like fabulous products
sickening design aesthetically pleasing
and knowing where your products come
from is super important because small
changes in the way we shop can make a
big impact on personal health and the
world at large so they use a membership
model so they can keep the costs low and
pass on even more savings to all of
their customers you can make your first
purchase with no obligation plus they
plan a tree for every order place and
incorporate stability sustainability
into every part of the company um we
have a great deal for you guys if you
want to get 15 off your first order
public goods
has a no minimum purchase they are so
confident that you will love their
products and come back again and again
that they are giving you 15 to spend on
your first purchase plus right now
receive your choice of either a free
pack of bamboo straws or the reusable
food storage wraps with your order have
the bamboo straws they're very good you
have nothing to lose just go to
publicgoods.com toast and use the code
toast at checkout that's
p-u-b-l-i-c-g-o-o-d-s dot com
forward slash toast to receive 15 off
your first order publicgoods.com toast
or use the code toast thank you claudia
first story
david schwimmer is not dating jennifer
aniston despite online rumors rep says
so i'm sure you guys all saw the rumors
yesterday that david schwimmer and
jennifer aniston are
canoodling
but they are not currently dating
despite the rumors after the tabloid
closer post published a report earlier
this week claiming that the two stars
were romantically involved a rep for
david schwimmer told the uk outlet the
sun that there is quote no truth to the
rumors so i saw the rumors but i also
followed jummah and jumaa said like hard
no so i never really believed them
because for the most part on stuff like
that dumas isn't always right but for
the most part they get it right um
but
i would be remiss devastated and
heartbroken if i didn't at least
fantasize about what a world would look
like with the two of them together right
and i guess at the special um they
talked about how they had a crush on
each other like throughout the years but
they it was never at the right time one
of them was always in a relationship
they were kind of like passing ships so
it kind of is like a nice
you know maybe them both finding out
that they were into each other at the
reunion sparked and they're both single
sparked them going out now yeah but that
didn't happen i think they always knew
like back when the show was on they knew
that the other had feelings for them but
like life just got in the way and i do
agree i would have put like a beautiful
bow on this whole story if this is how
it ended but we live
in a sad world and we don't get happy
endings like this so i didn't believe it
but i did kind of fantasize about what
that would look like and how wonderful
it would be
one because in
obviously just like if you're a friends
fan it's just like life imitating art
and it's stunning but then also it just
made me like kind of happy for jen like
i do think that could be the one
relationship that would get her out of
this brangelina endless tabloid cycle
like i think that could be it yeah like
the one that would one-up because it's
very very difficult for her to find
someone who like the public will ever
care more about and to get out of the
shadow like even when she was in that
really long-term relationship with
justin thoreau all of the tabloids was
like yeah well what does brad think like
it was just so toxic because he no
offense is nobody like nobody cares but
if she had this you know david schwimmer
thing there's so much history there he's
so famous like the people would chip so
hard potentially more than her and brad
and i think we would actually 20 years
later finally move on from that
narrative so honestly she should just
date him for that reason she should
think about it you know why not why not
i don't know i'm sure at this point they
know each other a little too well and
it's like you could never
you could never look at someone like
that in a romantic way when you've like
seen them inside and out well i do want
to say that one thing i thought the
friends reunion was kind of missing or
just like didn't really give me any
insight on is it had taken them so long
to all get in the same room together and
the girls were really friendly but there
was
a lot of moments where the cast had like
alluded to someone not being down for a
reunion someone being difficult
and i assumed it was always like david
trimmer who was like toxic in the group
and after the show like
kind of did his own thing um and they
never really like they said we haven't
all been together in you know why not
and i do think like david schwimmer and
i don't know this for a fact like is
like a dick you think he's the one who
wouldn't get together i do
it's not any of the girls so three of
them are best friends they hang out all
the time um so it's definitely one of
the guys and i remember just like seeing
interviews where like
everyone was alluding to the fact that
it was david schwimmer okay but then
also like i want to think david trimmer
is a dick but then
do you remember um when he trolled on
the internet basically this guy i want
to say in london was caught on security
footage stealing from a grocery store
and they like sent the picture out um
to the news outlets
sorry two news outlets being like if you
know this guy and the guy was literally
like david trimmer like the guy looked
so and so david schwimmer like set up a
photo shoot where he like was stealing
from a grocery store and was looking in
the security camera so then i'm like
well if you do that you have to be funny
and like nice no you might just have
like good pr and a decent sense of humor
but it still doesn't make you funny or
nice that's true that's true yeah okay
i'm just like torn like who is the real
david schwimmer if anyone is related to
him like as your uncle like is he nice
does he come to family barbecues i feel
like he definitely doesn't he definitely
does him he definitely doesn't host them
but he might not even attend
are you ready for our next story which
it was just like some exciting news and
something that i've been wanting to talk
about sure addison ray talks kourtney
kardashian's cameo and he's all that she
says we got very fortunate so i don't
know if you have seen that he saw that
trailer i have before you have and i
don't know if you at home have seen it
it's on addison race instagram it looks
so [ __ ] good do you agree yes it
looks very cute i mean i'm always
skeptical of trailers obviously but she
looks great the premise it really looks
like they remained they didn't touch the
premise they just flipped it flipped it
she was just gender swap which is so 20
21 um so i am very hopeful for sure yeah
and she looked like she was a decent
actress i totally agree and fans were
definitely shocked to see that kourtney
kardashian makes a cameo it was shocking
in the movie so she opened up addison
spoke to access on tuesday about
courtney's cameo in the project when
asked how courtney landed the small role
in the movie addison said i thought it'd
be so incredible she's an amazing friend
of mine amazing mentor and person we got
very fortunate that it ended up working
out and i'm very thankful for her when
asked how the two get along addison said
she and courtney quote are really
similar in temperament and interests i
think both of us are very honest people
and we like a lot of the same things it
started off with both of us just loving
to work out we were doing that together
a lot she's just a very real person and
honest she's been so helpful to me in
every way she's such a good person to
lean on well honestly now that i know
that working out is the way to korean
kardashian's heart i can safely say
we'll never be friends right um which is
upsetting because i just wasn't like
i shouldn't see that for myself learning
today that i would never be friends with
kourtney kardashian but i do have to say
that's what first of all that whole like
speech about courtney kardashian is so
lovely like glowing review i feel like
it kind of really just speaks to the
person addison wright is like she's
really like a nice girl yeah i hope like
again i don't know her but no i know
yeah and honestly so nice of courtney to
do this like courtney's obviously too
famous like being a teen drama but the
synergy is so fabulous i'm sure it was
like really fun courtney acted in the
first season of dave she was pretty good
like i actually think this will be great
i think it's going to be great i think
it's going to be so fun to see her the
movie comes out pretty soon i'm really
just excited for it like it's a reboot
that looks like
it's going to hold its own and the
original
what's her name rachel rachel lee cook
is in it as adam
as addison's mom right yes that's like a
great way to kind of come full circle i
love that and it but it also looks like
they use social media but like i think
in a way that's not cringy yes netflix
is very touch and go with how they refer
to social media like what they did to
social media in emily in paris
disgraceful but how they use like phones
in like
to all the boys they love before and
even the kissing booth like really cute
it's like actually how teens communicate
right so i think that this movie is
going to be really good stuff and i
think it's just going to be the
beginning of a
long beautiful career for addison me too
i'm very excited and also it's worth
mentioning speaking of netflix you know
the kissing booth 3 dropped today i
heard you complaining about it this
morning yeah for those who have been on
the journey with me i was so in love
with kissing booth one i couldn't talk
to ben for like two days i was like
you're not
jacob lordy like leave me alone like i
i'm 17 and i live in l.a like don't talk
to me and then i watched all the boys i
loved before and i was like oh my god i
didn't think the kissing booth could get
any better this is the best movie i've
ever seen to all the boys i loved before
then i went back to watching the kissing
booth after kind of having my tastes
elevated
and i was like i cannot believe i ever
even finished this movie it's so
atrocious like
it's horrible it's offensive actually
and then the kissing booth 2 came out
and i didn't even finish it so
i'm not going to be watching the kissing
booth 3 i i believe they left the
kissing booth 2 on a cliffhanger like
she got into two schools east coast west
coast east coast west coast where will
she go noah's on the east coast
lee the brother are those their names
noah
at least does sound familiar yeah and
lee and noah for sure lee's on the west
coast like whatever's so dumb um
and also like just the sheer fact that
jacob lordy and joey king broke up after
the first movie and then had to film two
other movies together when he they
clearly despised each other there's no
twilight no no no and even sometimes i
think that people can work together
after breaking up it's very hard but
i think they might be jacob lordy and
joey king might be the two worst people
to ever do but like they had the most
tension they didn't even film half their
scenes together you could tell because
they couldn't be in the same room that's
really so they're on par with filming
high school musical the musical the
series like season two
yeah i actually think probably olivia
rodrigo had it worse just because like
she's super young and like
it was probably really tough yeah
but that's like an interesting
thing to go down that's why it's a great
one cast mates date but it's also
potentially no but it's great because
it's what sets
the chemistry it sets the great movies
from the good ones have you seen any
episodes of riverdale ever since um cole
sprouse and lily reinhart broke up i
think i have i watch i watched last
season i watch the seasons when they're
done so i think i have one season to
watch
but are they still together in the show
spoiler alert when i was last watching
yeah i think they'll always be together
they really are end game but then it
fast forwarded like five years or
something are they end game because like
i always thought that like archie and
betty were end gaming like comic books i
think archie and betty are end game in
the show of course in the comic books
for sure but in the show they really
like made it clear that like betty and
jug had our end game and also like
varchy is end game i love archie so much
i did too but like i don't know
there's something about barchy that's
just no worth exploring varchi is you're
there's something about barchy no ugh no
no no he needs the edge of veronica to
make him interesting well also can we
talk about for a minute those comic
books yeah i
likes literally used to live and i used
to read them over and over again like
those they were like short little
magazines yeah i'm used to reading them
at camp right
so good so good i wonder if i picked one
up now like would i even be moderately
interested in it because it's like dumb
i don't know but it's not dumb because
it's like
so much goes into it you know no totally
so much character development so much
character development like so much
artwork like it's not it's actually not
dumb yeah like i always wanted to be
veronica like i knew i was about a yeah
no i'm not no i think you're actually
probably closer to veronica i really
wanted to be veronica
and i think actually as this i stopped
reading them like years ago but i think
as a storyline developed jughead came
out as queer right yeah
yes that was a nice development that
they did i think
this spoiler alert um yeah i took a
class in college that was all about um i
forgot what the name of the class was
but at one point we studied comics
and i'm pretty sure that archie spoiler
in the comics dies
yeah
very sad dramatic yeah
and just like that is like a moment of
like a time capsule of my life like i
had looked back on so fondly like
remember those um what were those circle
stationaries that you would like collect
oh what were they called those circle
postcards and they had like um
like cartoons yeah and they were like
valuable are they like david and goliath
or something or were those pajamas
was a camp brand but not the postcards
hold on circle camp postcards this is
gonna be they were collectibles like you
wouldn't actually send the postcards
margo lewin will know yeah for sure
yeah she'll know in two seconds hold on
there was so much fun stuff like that i
know that was like my favorite part of
going to camp
what were those postcards that we used
to collect at camp question mark they
were circle
postcards and they were like collectible
i think they're a circle something
they like i thought like if i ever oh no
i just got a text from con ed heatwave
in your area
if there's a blackout with the heat like
seriously i'm moving to alaska i'm going
to make a gazpacho
i didn't know what you're going to say
because
when it's a snow day we make a chili
when there's a heat wave to make a
cousin no that's fair i mean i would
rather die than any gazpacho like i hate
soup and cold soup it can be quite
refreshing
maybe i'll make like an ice cream based
gazpacho
nice with a little chocolate syrup
ganache
anyways addison's movie comes out august
27th i i really am so excited and i also
wanted to say because on the same day i
did see the trailer for cinderella oh
and i am this is me walking back ooh
what i said because it looks really good
really
and i think the article made it seem
more annoying than it is okay okay um
also really quickly just because he
brought up camille cameo i saw the most
interesting tick tock today oh my god oh
my god the disrespect oh my god you're
not disrespecting new york times with
selling authors [ __ ] i'm so sorry sorry
you're not respecting um i saw this tick
tock today that i thought was really
interesting and i had known some of the
facts but like a bunch of songs that
camilla cabello has turned down or
either backed out of like i think
everyone knows that she got um the
middle
the middle and like two weeks before it
was supposed to come out her team
advised her not to because savannah was
climbing the charts so that one i
actually
understood the reasoning behind it
because havana did end up going number
one she also um
pulled out of closer halsey so baby pull
me closer it was about to come out okay
and she also recorded a demo of god as a
woman and actually wrote a couple of the
verses and then was like it's not my
vibe and gave it to her on a grande so
like
that's like she's over three
no she's not i mean closer i don't
understand but the song wound up being
so good and i actually can't imagine
camilla on it and i hear what she's like
god is a woman like isn't my favorite
song i have to say when i heard the demo
do not come for me i just thought the
style
fit camilla cabello so much better it's
actually all the demos are online like
you can go googling bb rexa actually has
a demo of the middle 14 girls tried out
for the middle um
and it's really interesting to hear
their takes and i thought the god is a
woman camilla cabello version was
actually really good okay interesting
yeah i'll check it out are you ready for
our next story hold on i got a text from
margaret about that i got a 10.
they're called circle cards that's what
i said circle something
they're called circle cards okay maybe
that's just what we called them
circle cards that just like doesn't you
know you're really wondering something
that you find out and it like feels so
good hold on but like when i'm gonna
google circle cards that's not what i'm
gonna get you know i think that was just
what we called them
yeah like what's the brand there's a
brand and what was the david and goliath
brand was that clothing that was like
throwing rocks at them
violent
were they on pajamas
yes they were on pajamas they probably
did some other stuff too but like it was
those little cartoons that was like yeah
remember those uh shoes
yeah you know actually like i didn't
have a pair of floaties and that was
kind of like my personal cross to bear
yeah because they were like expensive
and i remember our parents would be like
you want rubber flip-flops like it was
but everyone had them at camp and there
was a girl in my bunk oh actually they
were twins
and their dad owned a store in the city
that sold the floaties so he sent up
like a whole box of floaties for the
bank for the bunk and jackie i was like
literally walking on cloud nine
literally and figuratively i'm like i
got [ __ ] floaties gotta get me a pair
of floaties they're kind of like styling
now yeah that's they're they work well
they were always cool except they would
like tear after wearing them one time
right but that's also because we wore
them in the shower
totally
and also like we wear them to the shower
like and to the camp social like they
were just kind of like casual attire
business attire give you a shoe that can
do both black tie
are you ready for our next story i don't
know walking down memory lane kind of
has me feeling all nostalgic like i want
to digitize some of my old photos and
videos 100
that was a really good segue 100 legacy
is an affordable no not sorry start over
legacy box is an affordable way to have
the priceless moments from your aging
home movies and photos safely stored in
a format that you can access and share
wherever you want imagine a lifetime of
memories right in your pocket even
better legacy boxes offering 50 off this
week what
um
what memories jackie this is a question
for you do you kind of
envision in your head you know we have
stored somewhere and like you're just
dying to kind of like some definitely
like
um
al burton roper two thumbs up
performances that we've done as children
albert and roper you know like the
critics
what the critics
ebert and roper who's that two thumbs up
eberton
okay
like theater critics okay it's just like
but it's also from the kanye song like
okay two thumbs up okay so ebert and
robert so what memories
some really award-winning performances
of ours because we used to give we used
to perform in our living room like every
single night in full like drag
we had this we had this chest full of
like like like gaps
gowns crowns that were all from like you
know costume stores but like we thought
they were literally like chanel they
were fighting over dresses no every
night like after dinner was dinner and a
show in the house and we would put on
like red lipstick
and we would just we would work
no we would work yeah so that's what i
want to see so with legacy box you can
reclaim all the priceless footage you
haven't been able to see in years and
the service couldn't be simpler you use
their kit to safely send the moments you
want preserved their team will create a
digital archive by hand and then you'll
receive your new copies either stored on
a cloud the thumb drive dvd
along with the original media that you
send them and with their tracking system
you can monitor every step of the
process so you always know the originals
are being taken care of legacy box has
helped over 1 million families including
ours restore and protect their most
cherished moments it's really such a
nice gift to get for someone in your
life because like we grew up in the age
of vhs and try watching a vhs now we
have like a whole storage unit full of
them and we sent a lot of it to legacy
box first of all it was so efficient
streamlined they kept you you know
in communication with you along the way
it was fabulous so visit legacybox.com
toast to take advantage of this limited
time offer for 50 off and discover the
magic of bringing your past back into
view and if you want to take advantage
of this exclusive offer and use their
kit whenever you're ready so if you're
not ready to do it yet just get the
discount and then do it that's
legacybox.com
toast to save 50 off legacybox.com
toast thank you for that a pleasure
next up i usually don't like talking
about hair style changes news but
machine gun kelly revealed a dramatic
head tattoo as he shaved his hair off
the 31 year old rapper posted a photo to
social media on tuesday revealing he had
recently shaved off all his signature
blonde locks this is quite the identity
shift given that his instagram bio
simply reads the blonde dawn the pick
showed off a prominent blonde tom or the
grand dom
both the pick showed off a prominent
tattoo on the top of his head which can
be seen in the screenshot below have you
seen it yeah the arrow right
yeah
oh no it's not an arrow it's like a
symbol it's like a triangle with a cross
in the middle or no maybe like a dime
it's like a rhombus i'm not gonna
pretend that i understand
um and i'm just really shocked by it i
know because
i feel like i've
i've said this many times like i'm very
into machine gun kelly you know um
physically and emotionally of course and
of course musically
but artistically creatively yeah
metaphysically
but um it's gonna be a no for me maybe
it's just it's first of all it's the
worst photo like it's so blurry he's
like sitting in his car it's a selfie
maybe if i see it stylized with the look
but i know it's giving me very um
i didn't want to say
don't say yeah but i think we all know
what it's giving
i think we all know what's good we all
know what it's giving there's a lot of
people who look like that in prison oh
that's not like what i was thinking but
what were you thinking
like he yeah he he looks [ __ ] crazy
like honestly yeah um i mean hair grows
back so that's fine and i guess even if
he gets back to those like
blonde locks he'll always have like the
widow's peak now part of his tattoo
showing oh you're right you know because
it goes down the forehead do you think
that the
the tattoo was always under the hair
do you think that no okay i was one guy
i was wondering that but then no because
like look at this picture he doesn't
have it that far down but
now zooming in it could be a wig it
could be a a just a um
oh i would love that it could be
makeup and prosthetics for a music video
or something because
i don't think he would do this i don't
but also if it is a real tattoo and he
had it before his hair was super long
and he's been wearing it like in front
of his
like hanging in front of his forehead so
like but look self-conscious about the
way we say forehead now people are like
i know forehead is that he's supposed to
say it that sounds so wrong
foreign kelly so either he shaved his
head and got the tattoo or this is kind
of like a a look for a video a stud i'm
gonna i'm gonna hope and pray on stunt
me too
and i hope if it's not a stunt he got me
guns kind of input not approval but
input so i think when you're gonna make
a dramatic change to your appearance you
don't need your partner's approval
necessarily because it's your
body do whatever you want but like
they have to look at you every day so it
should be a little conversation of a
collaborative decision
i think for a man yeah
but like for a woman like i'm gonna do
what i want like like the first time i
got botox or lip filler like me and ben
had like a full conversation about it
and now if like we go to the plastic
surgeon and she has like a new technique
like i'm i'm not talking about about it
right but because at the end of the day
it doesn't really change your appearance
and if you didn't tell ben that you got
botox you would never know okay you came
home with your head shaved
on your scalp lip filler it doesn't
change your appearance like that much it
depends on what you get but um say you
were gonna get a pixie cut would you run
it by ben
no i would just run off a cliff
because i'm like not doing that no but
like say you were gonna get a face
tattoo okay would you run it by then
yeah of course that's what i'm saying
that's unless it's like a surprise that
it's like i heart ben on my face it's
for him yeah right i mean that's the
only way he wouldn't be mad yeah okay
are you ready for our next story yeah
it's a little tv news that i think is
going to shock you because it shocked me
a little bit
the white lotus has been renewed by hbo
for a second season with a new cast of
characters at a new resort yeah a new
premise it's giving me very much why
women kill like
season you fall in love with the
characters there's a whole story series
then the next season i'm sure there are
other shows like this but this is the
one that comes to mind and then the next
season it's like we don't know anyone
it's a totally new show new cast new
location new house new everything yes so
apparently white lotus is you know super
buzzy and people are really liking it i
don't know them but some people are
actually so true detective okay i saw in
toast after dark that some people were
really liking it um no a lot of people
are really liking it
disliking it i just like
i just it's so stupid no i'm not
disliking it either i just feel like i
watch it all weekend and i only watch
two episodes like that's the sign of a
not good show yeah i started like
catching up two days ago and i don't
even think i finished the episode i was
watching i heard that episode five is
like where [ __ ] starts but like really
have to watch five hours just to get
some like action and it's just like the
whole show is so frustrating like i just
want to shake some of these people oh my
god totally you know totally
especially connie britton's son
oh i know but i feel like he's so far
the only one well i guess you're a
little bit behind me but so far he's the
only one who's like
having like allowing
me because his phone got washed away but
like he sleeps on the beach and the tide
takes his phone and so like he doesn't
have one so he has to like snorkel with
his dad and he's like starting to get
like into like just like the beautiful
scenery around him so i feel like so far
he's the only one who's like developing
a little growing growing the daughter
connie burton's daughter i think is my
least favorite yeah character
she's like a really annoying yes she's
really annoying i don't know where it's
going with her but i just can tell she's
like a toxic friend totally you know
yeah no i'm just like i probably will
finish it but i've had so much on my
content plate between the olympics and
love island and just like
all the housewives like i just
obx love is blind after the altar like
there's just so much like i'm choking
and white lotus is having to take a
backseat i'm sorry yeah but it is nice
watching a show maybe after watching all
this reality tv it's nice to watch a
show that's so stunningly done you know
it's got it gotta visit the white lotus
right and
apparently they filmed it during
lockdown they took over this whole hotel
and while so many other productions and
crews had to stop working they were
actually able to film because they
created their own bubble right that's
cool that is cool but then like the next
time they want to take over the hotel
it's probably going to cost more yeah no
probably no one was at the hotel yeah
yeah
okay so that's exciting content news and
this the finale of white lotus is on
sunday so i think we should if there's
going to be a big drop like the undoing
we should be caught up okay
i'll do my best but like honestly no
promises i'm so
over
overwhelmed with content yeah and i
personally and so maybe if you don't
want to watch normalize not watching
because i'm over watching things that
don't bring me joy inner peace and
some sort of like
betterment yeah but i also think that
you have a very high bar for that
whereas like i do the same but my bar is
pretty low yeah but then it's like funny
like i still have the tolerance for
white lotus and you don't
it's so bad
it's like and i honestly i'm just
shocked that people are loving it i'm
like what am i not seeing i'm like it's
perfect i love connie britton i love
jennifer coolidge like it should be like
my show yeah like jennifer coolidge with
her massage like i'm just not
understanding the whole thing yeah i
agree
but maybe it's a slow burn with a big
payoff we'll see are you ready for our
fifth and final story that's going to
lead into our tv recap
what is it it's a final story
[Music]
do
[Music]
i started out too high on that one yeah
and you were like a little off tempo but
i'm not judging
sounds like you are anyways fit the
final story that has to do with real
houses of new york will lead into our tv
recapture into medley lists her
berkshire's estate bluestone manor on
airbnb she was also on watched rap
inside last night which i found to be
appalling i didn't watch and i'm just
like there must be really struggling to
get new york-based guests and so i'm
just going to chalk it up to that no i'm
not going to chalk it up to that i'm
going to chuck it up too like
she will be back on the show at some
point
but and given this news i think that's
for the best right i think she's
struggling financially the former real
housewives of new york city star listed
her berkshire's home on airbnb with the
proceeds benefiting the ronald mcdonald
i'm sorry i take back everything i said
i'm a [ __ ] i'm a disgusting i didn't
know that either i didn't know that i'm
sorry
she said let me tell you when they first
approached me of course i was like well
first of all there's something magical
about blue stone manor it's almost like
an urban legend people think i'm like
cinderella in that castle you see at
disneyland like i don't think people
really get it's real in their minds it's
a sort of stage set that was made for
bravo
right
um but obviously the house is super
iconic now and it's actually a pretty
good business idea i mean knowing that
the persons are going to charity is
really like nice and now it's like of
course you know
the more the merrier but when i first
saw the story i thought this was just
like a new business project for her but
like blue stone manor could be you know
the gracie mansion of housewives fans
boring no for sure it's definitely like
a good business you mentioned graceland
oh oh oh my gracie mansion
um yes i agree but i just don't think
that's realistic seeing as how it's her
primary residence
and it's like so
emotion it's such like an emotional
place for her i don't think she wants
like a million strangers and i'm sure
for the charity one it's gonna be
expensive like not a million people
probably like a couple people who book
it and i'm pretty sure i saw there's
only like two dates that it's available
it's like one night only this is like a
special thing that she's doing but i
think like just um
thinking about this holistically maybe
there are some other iconic homes in the
housewives community where other women
could do this too it's like you know
going on a real housewives tour when you
go to new york city like it
could be like a little museum of sorts
yeah no sonia could do it with your
townhouse a hundred percent
what else let me think other like i mean
heather's home in the berkshires that
has no air conditioning no but like they
went to the bert
during his house every season for like
five years they went there once i don't
know if there's anything else like that
in the
housewives franchise that they go to
every year
yeah ramona's house in the hamptons
kind of stunning yeah not my
aesthetic on the outside but that piece
of property if she put it up for rent on
airbnb she would get people who just
like want to go to the hamptons it
wouldn't be like this icon no i have
seen ramona's house on out east it like
she does rent it out the winter months
and like she probably makes a ton of
money from it because it's like a it's a
mansion yeah she probably makes like 30
grand a month maybe more so i feel like
maybe if this charity endeavor goes well
i could see dorinda
making this a business yeah even though
i actually can't see it just because
it's a place that like is so near and
dear to her heart like richard bought it
for her it's like her place with richard
richard i don't know if she wants people
like roaming the halls yeah
but brian has been he said it's amazing
for the right price though yeah let them
roam let them roam well that's a great
segue into the real housewives of new
york recap and
the love island recap which i can't wait
to get into so our tv recap is brought
to you by liquid iv the hot summer
months are here and we need to be
proactive about keeping our bodies
fueled and hydrated making hydration a
priority helps us feel healthier on a
day-to-day basis and it fuels us to be
our highest potential one stick of
liquid iv in 16 ounces of water hydrates
you faster and more efficiently than
water alone so if you're like you know
tight on time check out liquid iv um it
contains five essential vitamins it has
more vitamin c than an orange and as
much potassium as a banana it's super
effective they have an optimal ratio of
glucose sodium and potassium so it
delivers water and nutrients directly
into your bloodstream it's a perfect
balance to help you hydrate more quickly
and effectively than water alone
it'll hydrate you faster all you do is
pour one of their packets at 16 ounces
it's powder you pour it into water and
that water just starts to hydrate you
give you nutrients go directly into your
blood stream it's everything of the sort
and they're on a mission to change the
world they're donating 4 million
servings in response to cobin 19. um
they've donated over 11 million servings
globally they have a ton of different
flavors so you can find one you like and
it's fun to try the different flavors
they're all really really good grab your
liquid iv in bulk
nationwide at costco or you can get 25
off if you order online at liquidive.com
and use the code toast at checkout
that's 25 off anything you order when
you get better hydration today use the
promo code toast at liquidity.com
promo code toast at checkout okay real
housewives of new york before we get
into the train wreck that was ramona
because that's obviously worth talking
about the sacrilegious event that took
place last night no that's not even what
i was gonna say um
my god was leah annoying me so much on
the facetime and i know like when you
look at it ramona was being rude like
telling her to shut up oh what's rude is
that like you're at this woman's house
who put together this evening for you
and you're all passing around a phone
talking to this girl through the phone
first of all i understand that it was
like leah wanted to do the blessing like
i really do but like honestly she made
the whole event about her when she
wasn't even there she was being so
[ __ ] awake ebony can you lift me up
ebony i can't hear shut up like this
woman's talking you're in her house and
it was distracting all the women who are
so easily distracted and i saw a lot of
people being like ramona was being mean
to leah i'm sorry i would have done the
same thing it was bothering me so much i
didn't think she was mean for one second
she literally said leah we love you we
wish you were here we miss you but we
can't keep bringing the conversation
back to you and like i don't know what
leah expected like when you come in on
zoom you're sitting you don't get a neck
too you should get backstage or if
you're going to be facetime on the table
yeah you're going to be the size of the
delta fish like
what do you think was going to happen no
totally so that was really really
frustrating and i also felt like the
women um
attacking ramona already for just
telling leah to kind of shut up was not
that's why she was like in a weird place
but oh my god like her saying about all
the jewish people
all the jewish people were mean to her
in high school and then leah was like it
probably wasn't just jewish people
everyone hated you in high school she
was really i wanted to shake her and
tell her to shut the [ __ ] up because
like she just made herself look so bad
and it was more than just her usual like
not wanting to talk about serious stuff
it was she took her to another level and
then like running away and crying and
then being like i had to pee well really
you didn't say you had to pee you got up
and said i'm getting up because no one's
listening to me so she was like
gaslighting everyone she was being so
insane and then that poor woman archie
even though like her event was really
bizarre like with the
like the decorations on the table and
there was like a cage in her living room
did you see that this the thing behind
her it was like a metal case it looks
like a classroom the aesthetic was very
bizarre and the event turned into a very
bizarre evening i did feel bad for her
she was like i want to apologize on
behalf of the jews like that's really
not what this event was about and
honestly i was actually really
interested to hear what she was about to
say before everyone interrupted her like
you know the long history of the
communities the long relationship of the
black community in the jewish community
like two oppressed communities i was
actually really interested in we never
got there right and that's probably what
i'm most mad at ramona about like that
she couldn't just she could have said
whatever she wanted to say like at a
later date in the conversation but she
was just taking up all the oxygen and i
mean the whole episode i was
i was
curious about what was going to happen
at the shabbat dinner at black shabbat
and like just what it was going to be
about and the sorry the black seder oh
my god yeah for those who don't know
seder is a meal you have on one of the
holidays it's a passover you've had no
judaism like it's funny you have it like
at one time in the year if shabbat is
once a week by the way also then
referring to it as black sabbath oh
that's like a band that was so it's ozzy
osbourne's man right they were being
funny like about the verbiage i have to
say so i was going into the whole
evening with an open mind like excited
to see what they were going to show
about judaism and what we like who we
were gonna hear from and
it just all was like a big
failure on so many levels and
maybe if leah had been there
it would have been better just because
like she is converting and it is
interesting and i thought she did do a
very nice job with the prayer yeah of
course but like oh my god up leading up
to that i literally wanted to throw the
phone if i was remembering i would have
thrown the phone down the toilet but the
whole thing made no sense and why are we
in new jersey at archie's like who is
she why are these women in new jersey i
literally felt like i just cut two real
housewives of new jersey like i just
didn't understand and i feel like ebony
didn't never got a chance or maybe was
cut to like make clear what we're doing
here yeah you know
yeah i just think like
i really do commend ebony because she's
really trying to bring a lot of her
culture and other cultures into this
group
and it's she just like
is now over two
yeah harlem night and now this like
they don't want to they don't care you
know and i thought actually the most
well behaved a lot of people aren't even
talking about how like sonia was also
atrocious atrocious the blacks like she
was just sorry i'm not pc and then she
apparently gets drunk in peace in the
driveway like her behavior is so
attractive like she makes ever like
ramona is so annoying on her own but
then you have like sonia parrotting
ramona like just attacking everything
she's saying it's like
there's two annoying people in the room
and like sonia was i don't know if she
thought she was helping but she did she
really wasn't and it also started she
started like it's so weird that tony and
ramona are so close when like sonia
jumps down ramona's
um she told her a [ __ ] like the second
they sat down right just about what she
said to leah which wasn't even
really [ __ ] or anything so like of
course ramona's already like in ramona
mode and like so just like she doesn't
if she actually is trying to like help
move the conversation forward she's
doing a terrible job the honestly the
person who deserves an honorable mention
is the most well-behaved luanne honestly
forgot she was there because she just
sat like she was supposed to and shut up
and like even if she didn't care about
what anyone was saying you're respectful
in someone's house like of what's going
on and then ramona going into the
kitchen to get food like she's an animal
yeah she's so hard to defend sometimes
but sometimes i really feel like she
does get
like an unfair treatment but then
sometimes she acts like she did last
night and it's impossible to defend her
well i will say i watched her last week
on watch what happens live and they
played like a segment like do you regret
that and andy says do you regret how you
acted at black shabbat and she really
really did but then they brought up all
these other times that she acted kind of
badly on the show and she was like no i
don't yeah so she actually didn't really
even say that she felt bad about black
shabbat and he like co-worked so he was
like you should you acted atrociously
she understood that yeah so i mean maybe
we'll have to wait till the reunion
because like she should have been on
watch what happens like last night or
like next week totally um
but
i was just like wholly confused after
the episode yeah it was so weird and
honestly i was laughing at those uh two
of ebony's friends that are their names
who were just like sitting there
watching this train wreck yeah and
drinking margaritas it was so funny
imagine it's like it's a circus it's a
circus and it's actually crazy there's
only four of them at that dinner i was
just thinking i'm like this these this
is the whole cast like leah is on the
phone whatever like this is it like this
is as good as it gets it's crazy
yeah it was honestly the whole episode
was a train wreck like you couldn't look
away no i just want to say that i
actually think ramona um would be a very
good realtor
yes oh that's what she has such realtor
energy she has realtor energy she's a
million fancy friends and the guy was
like real estate is a really competitive
business and she's like i'm a really
competitive person she really is such a
hustler like she has a number of jobs
right now like she doesn't need to like
keep keep working um but she like wants
to work and do more and learn and i
actually
kind of enjoyed the scene me too that
apartment was stunning right so i was
like on a rem i was in a good place with
ramon at the beginning of the episode
watching that um
and then i wasn't watching that segment
with the apartment like after hunting
for an apartment all day like was an
especially tough blow oh i'm sure it was
like rubbing salt in my window yeah
because it was like a double-decker
terrace so it's like columns outside the
terrace like
standalone tub tub with a big window
kitchen with you know laundry and
all of these amenities wine fridge if it
makes you feel any better it doesn't
seem like the location that you would
want to be in because i actually know
where exactly where that building is is
it where it's across the street from
bloomingdale's
oh yeah it's pretty sick wow yeah
um so that's me
it was a good episode honestly it was
probably the one that i thought i had
the most to say about in the last couple
weeks but
and whatever ebony looked stunning um
she did and the only other thing that
happened was sonia's date which i found
really interesting and it's really crazy
how sonia can behave like the most
normal person yes of all time like she
was so [ __ ] normal like it was crazy
i felt like i was watching like a play
like she was not being her she was
literally like being the mo she was
being sonia
morgan yeah like
and just where is that energy at other
times i know when the guy was talking
about his hernia it was like a jelly
doughnut i was cracking up and then also
she was like perked up when he said he
had a house in ibiza right or wherever
and then in south france and then he
sold it right it was so funny i actually
thought that was a really interesting
and like her commentary about her date
was just really great and i just i could
use some more of that sonia yeah it was
really cute is that the guy from ebony's
matchmaker yes okay
not a bit not a terrible map not at all
i thought he looked better in the show
than he did in his picture but yeah i
thought the opposite i actually thought
he
was the uh like i thought he looked
exactly like his photo and that's on
sonia for
not looking at the photo yeah also
imagine how old do you think he is and
he's going on the show
he's going on a first date on a reality
tv show like
imagine that i know imagine having
everything we've ever dreamed don't you
want it maybe can't you see it kinda i
mean first audition after college i get
the lead apart from me well of course
you gotta believe it
that's how i felt
that's how i felt i hope they go out
again though me too yeah um he looks a
little bit like frenchie that old guy
shoes today yeah i missed when someone
had like a boyfriend me too except not
like the young
like children yeah
okay then love island was a really
interesting episode especially given the
fact that like ever since cash cinco
like all the good people left josh
shannon it has been super lackluster i
felt really torn let me tell you why
because
the challenge was interesting in the
sense that like it they really like live
in their own bubble and it's like a
smack from the real world yes
but i do think like in these times i
don't know if the show should like be
giving energy to people's like toxicity
on the internet do you know what i mean
like i i felt conflicted about it
because i like liked watching it but
also i'm like think of their mental
health like
bailey was crying like i don't know i
just feel like the boys like were able
to brush it off but i i feel like i
don't know if that's what we should be
doing that's a good point i hadn't
thought of it like that i feel like the
tweets that they chose that were not
super flattering weren't like
disgusting troll tweets no of course it
was what people are thinking like
especially with olivia and corey like
this is a farce
right and so i wouldn't put the olivia
emmy tweet in like a that i think it's a
fair critique of what we're watching on
the show and like the challenge does
need to be interesting so i would say
that i was fine with because that's what
a lot of people are thinking that's what
it looks like to us i would say the will
and cure stuff needed to come out that's
what happened last season with johnny
and sally and like
it was so bad but like bailey not being
genuine jeremy is the grim reaper yeah
like
funny true but like mean mean calling
trina leftovers was so mean and so not
true by the way no she keeps choosing
mark my words trina is gonna win
people love trina so much and they don't
really aren't invested in any of these
other couples they're very doubtful of
olivia and corey there's so much trauma
with will and kiera people trina is the
hero of the show fyi and i'm telling you
she's winning with her i love her so
much i didn't like her being called
leftovers i would agree with that and i
feel like some for some of the people
they just needed to find something mean
about them like when i watch bailey on
the show what i don't think she's not
genuine that's no like we never get to
see her that's how i would be doing that
my critique of her so i feel like they
just needed to like say something yeah
um but then bailey thinks that's what
all of america is thinking about her no
and like it makes them self-conscious
and you're already self-conscious being
on a show and just like having this
morsel of faith i think that the tweets
should have been relegated to like
things they've done yeah not personal or
just couples right or not but not like
personal attacks on their character i do
have to say like i did get misty-eyed
with the whole alanna thing um because
first of all i think she's like
literally the most gorgeous girl on the
show and i've never in my life watched a
show like this bathroom paradise
bachelor are you the one where anyone's
even remotely curvy like it's unheard of
when she walked in i was like so excited
and she's just so stunning and i love
that they gave her that tweet and i love
that she had that conversation she's
like of course i was self-conscious
about coming here like i had the
confidence like in myself but then like
to go on tv with all of you guys like
it's torture and i just thought that was
such a refreshing conversation and i
love alanna and honestly i would vote
for her to win too and i know people
don't like charlie because they think he
they did he did cash wrong by like
coming back from casa more with her and
then exploring other relationships even
though that's literally the point of the
show i don't think he's a bad guy i
think he's like misunderstood and i like
him in a line a lot i don't know if they
have a connection at all but separately
i like them i don't know i like them too
i feel like they could have a connection
and definitely something substantial
enough to warrant him moving on from
cash yeah but let's talk about the will
and kira stuff because i had a bit of a
change of heart i thought kyra me too
because i feel like
i had a lot of respect for her for
having enough self-awareness to be like
i have horse blind race blinders horse
blinders line like the things on the
side horse blinders blinders horse the
horses wear them yeah that's a good
point horse blinders i don't think she
called herself horse blinders no i'm
saying yeah yeah like she's all in on
someone she is so infatuated she cannot
see red flags so i actually had a lot of
respect for her for seeking out other
people's people she trusts like trina
and olivia seeking out their opinion
because she's like i'm so in it i can't
see anything am i missing something like
did he lie what do we know so i actually
had a lot of respect for that because it
takes like a really mature person to
know your own flaws
and i do think there's something really
weird about will i also think there's
something really weird about the fact
that they've been together since day one
and have never had the conversation
about what they want on the outside like
that's a red flag yeah so
i for me i
was kind of feeling like this whole time
like here like you're spineless but
actually
i don't feel that way
no i don't feel that way and i felt like
when she sat down with the girls in the
bedroom it was like so crazy intense
like everyone waiting for them to go to
sleep and like they're like having this
conversation in the 11th hour do you
feel like elena was being like a little
bit of a snitch no i feel like
well i just assumed the best in her
because i didn't take her i think she
went in there so that if there were no
girls they would have been like where
are the girls they all got up and got
the girls i'm happy they're having
conversation no it's not serious like
someone had to be the one who wasn't
going to be in the conversation i think
she actually took one for the team
because of course you want to be in the
interesting bailey really should have
went to bed too
yeah she didn't she just wanted to be in
on it she didn't read the room
but she also was actually giving pretty
good advice yes i agree so i was i was
grateful for her presence she was like
have you asked him if he wants a
girlfriend after this and she was like
no but what's really tough is like when
olivia and trina are talking about like
will and his weirdness
away from kiara it's like yeah we all
get it we all we all see it but like
when they're trying to verbalize that to
kyra it's it's kind of like this
intangible thing you sound like a
conspiracy theory yeah no it's like we
can't give you like aside from what he
did in casa more like they just get
weird vibes from him but it's not based
on like anything other than just like
their intuition yeah and so that's kind
of hard for kira to act on but i do
think she needs to just like press
matters further and
ask hard questions and she needs to like
get out of this like fog she's in just
because she's so in love with him and
it's hard to have a conversation with
someone who you're just obsessed with
and you want to see the best in and you
ask you have to get the nerve to ask a
question and they just shoot it down and
you're like okay but i don't really
think it's about casa moore because me
neither it's just about like his his
character i think they're seeing
something that like can't be translated
on tv you're right it is this intangible
thing but it's also worth mentioning
that amy west giovanni cash and cinco
did an instagram live and amy is like
really salty they were all like talking
[ __ ] about kira and basically amy and
wes amy and wes are like really mad that
they got booted off and they're just
like jabbing at everyone and they were
basically like first of all will and
karen knew each other before they were
like dm'ing and will i mean and kyra
knew everyone who was coming on she knew
where the house was she was so eager she
was like finding out all this
information like they didn't say how
they knew that or how she found out all
that information but everyone was like
great like yeah she knew who was coming
yeah she knew where the house was yes
she knew the whole vibe um
and then like a lot of kira's friends
are like speaking out being like no she
didn't like stop this character
assassination so there's really no way
to know like what she knew but i just do
feel like there's like this weird aura
around her and will like kind of
untrustworthy yeah so i don't know who
to think i just know for sure that
they're not winning no
and which is crazy because they're
literally in my opinion like the only
actual couple eligible couple and
i think that people who are friends like
trina and andre they have a better
chance of winning that's so crazy and i
really respect andre for not just like
faking a relationship with trina like
because he thinks like it's what america
wants like he's like yeah we're friends
like if something comes they're both
like yeah let's just keep hanging out if
we like each other great if not like we
can always be friends like i think
that's so normal and healthy and i love
them not like forcing this
relationship on us just because they
think it's what america wants agreed
also bailey and jeremy had a bit of a
breakthrough last night okay
jeremy's it was so frustrating small
steps for us but it was a big step for
jeremy he talked about his feelings his
insecurity
in his looks and now he just like
doesn't give a [ __ ] but like i actually
feel like last night we started to see
the side of jeremy that has kept him in
the house for so long funny like funny
like he's like
america hating me makes my hair look
good whoa like he was being funny the
guys are obsessed with him and there's
definitely something we are not seeing
yeah so it just like i felt like finally
we're back in like a decent place with
him and not just like what is this
person he's really bothersome sometimes
he is but like and i just wish he would
like give a little bit more to bailey i
like to any girl that he's with but
right now it's bailey and i i just want
i want love for him me too but i'm
concerned he's not capable of it like
trina
amy
bailey they all say the same thing after
being with jeremy for a few days like he
doesn't really treat me like a girl like
he's like friendly and he's high-fiving
me and he doesn't cuddle him we don't
kiss he's not words of affirmation they
all say the same thing and they all they
were like cuddling a little last night
they all communicated to him and he
doesn't receive it i understand and how
does he not see the pattern that
literally the four girls he's been
matched with here all have the same
complaint like yeah you're the problem
he's actually been with five girls who
florida and jenny jenny i always forget
about jenny yeah and they all see the
same thing like are we just friends like
yeah because that's the energy he gives
and he's not willing to like make a
change it must be so frustrating to be
in a relationship with him definitely
but like he does things in his own way
and maybe just needs a little bit more
um someone who's gonna be more patient
and be like i see in you the person that
i want to be with and maybe it takes
time like i don't know he's in these
like four-day relationships he's like
yeah i'm not giving you [ __ ] yeah
totally so i don't i don't know i just i
i don't think he's a bad guy a couple
other things that were revealed on that
very salacious instagram live with all
the cats who left is that remembering
kasich wasn't in an episode they said
she was sleeping upstairs with a
toothache she had to leave the villa to
go get a tooth pulled like she was in
major tooth pain which i feel like was
right before she left and she was
probably [ __ ] ready to go like when
you're in pain especially tooth pain
like you just want to be i feel like
everyone there is ready to go they keep
saying we don't know if today's gonna be
our last but it's like please be our
last i feel like ever since really like
shannon and josh left everyone is like
it's not fun anymore like i want to go
home yeah it's like when is this over
and i felt that way last time and they
were all like drinking and trying to
like pump each other up especially after
the tweets episode which i also think
came a little too late in the season i
think if it come more in the middle and
maybe like the tweets episode has caused
kira to open up her eyes that should
have happened episodes ago yeah like not
running after cause right as they're
about to go home yeah agreed i think
that
there's a lot of things they can and
should do differently next season but i
just have to say i'm coming um
nearing the end of my first season of
watching love island and i've so enjoyed
it like thank you so much for opening up
my eyes it's been so fun i feel like i i
started following so many new people
like so many good influencers like
followed cache and shannon like i
i have to follow trina actually she's
like a top of my life her instagram is
stunning is it okay please remind me um
if so just like had the best time and
honestly i thought it would be really
overwhelming to watch the same thing
every day but it's like it's actually so
much better yeah also i just want to say
i heard that on love island uk which
everyone always says is better when they
do um a dumping ceremony the people who
have just arrived at the house don't
participate at all they should and that
way um they can't be sent home and you
don't get stuck with the same people
it's like oh geez having to send each
other home yeah that's the flaw of the
u.s yeah like the only people that leave
it the people that got there yesterday
it's like nobody cares right and they
were watching and then saying five
people and now we're in the last week
and it feels tired and by the way olivia
does deserve an enemy actually i don't
think the acting's been even that good
because i didn't convince me but like do
you think that she has real feelings for
not even in the slightest not even in
the slightest
do you i no i don't know i i actually
like i really don't know i think that
they're
what i'm seeing is like i think that
they're trying to
it would just be disappointing if if a
couple won who wasn't together so i
think that like it's convenient for
everyone if it's olivia and cory are
really olivia and quarry it just can't
no i'm not voting for them i'm either
voting for a sooner vote for will and
kiara for having even like they have
chemistry for having made it through
that long
yeah no i'm voting for um
trina and andre or alana even though
atlanta just like and charlie have been
there for so short it's like not fair
like trina's been there since day one
audrey's been there for shorter
yeah but trina yeah truth has been there
for [ __ ] day one and keeps getting
[ __ ] over by everyone jeremy cinco
literally everyone yeah she's had
honestly the worst experience on the
show and she's been a good friend to
everyone still the whole time every
night looks so better than the next and
i was looking at pictures like from
behind the scenes like she was doing
everyone's makeup she was doing cash's
makeup like she's just a good [ __ ]
friend
okay she deserves to win we're voting
for trina i don't know i'm like really
into atlanta and charlie though even
though i don't know if they're into each
other yeah i just love elena like i just
love what she stands for yeah you should
follow her too
yes even though like in a year from now
i'm like going through my people i'm
like why am i following these people
like because you forget no but like
you'll follow them for a year yeah it'll
be a fun year
yeah well
um so the finale is on sunday ariel
vandenberg did a q a and
cause also in tonight's episode their
family members are coming that's what i
thought when the trina was running off
yeah so that always happens right before
the end so they can like meet the person
that they're dating that sounds boring
ask questions it's boring because no one
there is dating no but also just i feel
like it's boring like i actually don't
like the episode of hometowns like on
the bachelor yeah no it's always sweet
and they've been like so like cooped up
for so long they are like so happy to
see their family and it's just like it's
really cute this show is one way too
long
this particular season particularly yeah
i agree and i need shannon and josh i
know they're busy obviously and i
respect that i just like really want
them to do it live i need to hear from
them like how are they how's josh are
you still together how's the
relationship like tell us about the show
like i need them to be eligible to win i
know you know i was actually thinking
when trina like got up and ran last
night i'm like is it possible shannon
and josh return but like there's no way
no no but like we should be able to vote
for them on the app i agree they gave
they gave everything to like they put
the first three weeks of the show on
their back like josh was like the center
of the guys group shannon was the center
of the girls group their relationship
was so interesting
no it's honestly and i hate this phrase
it's the definition of a power couple
it's okay if you say it about it no i
still think it's a disgusting term like
um
so that's our love island recap and our
tv recap and that's our show anything
else you want to say talk about do
please no i will be preparing for the
redhead so to make sure to email us your
questions and i'm just oh so excited you
know it's never too late to become a
redhead and i feel like i i haven't been
stumping for the redheads in a while
stump stump away
so let's go instagram at the redheads um
i
it's a great community it really is and
you can start anytime pick up any book
there's an episode for you next month is
a snitch's choice which is always
everyone's favorite so it's really the
perfect time to become a redhead and
that's all
i wrote
everyone have an amazing day thank you
so much for listening to the morning
shows the millennial morning show where
we deliver the fast life stories that
you need to know every monday through
friday on youtube so if you're watching
this on youtube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
have radio cast box all the places
wherever you listen to podcasts find us
the morning toast and leave a five star
review about how beautiful
stunning
and smart we are hope you have an
amazing day and also if you're still
here listening even though
most people are because like they know
about the society season two leave a
book on our most recent instagram to
support the red house the red book
there's a lot of books have a great day
read book for the redheads thanks fun
thanks for your support always
you